En 1969, dans les profondeurs de l'espace, une
mystérieuse valise était déposée discrètement
sur le sol lunaire par des individus casqués. Que
contenait-elle ? Et pourquoi l'avoir oubliée sur place ?
Cinquante ans plus tard, uneéquipe scientifique continue
d'exploiter ce dispositif pour mesurer
la distance entre la Terre et la Lune.
Leur arme secrète ? Un télescopeéquipé d'un laser ultra puissant.
Viser la lune, ça ne fait pas peur aux physiciens.
Chaque jour, ils orientent le rayon laser
en direction de notre satellite naturel
pour venir frapper les réflecteurs
installés par les missions Apollo.
A partir de ces mesures, les chercheurs
vont pouvoir déduire la taille et la
composition du noyau de la Lune, et peut-être mieux comprendre comment elle s'est
formée il y a 4,5 milliards d'années.Cette technologie de visée laser a
également permis de découvrir que la lune
s'éloignait de la Terre de 3,8 cm chaque année.
Quelques centimètres pour la science,
mais un pas de géant pour la connaissance.